what could be greater than a king a hero
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be a non-spoilery breakdown of all the
early aquaman reviews they've been
screening the movie for a while now but
James want recently celebrated them
finishing the movie with all the visual
effects artists so it sounds like
whatever cut of the movie people have
been seeing it's a relatively final cut
we'll do a giveaway for IMAX tickets all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video all these recent reviews are from
California there's this area in the
North Valley where a lot of Hollywood
studios will test their movies out
because for some strange reason this
small area of the valley contains the
perfect slice of the demographics that
movie studios are trying to hit they
want to hit like the most normal people
they could possibly hit from all
demographic categories so because a lot
of the major Hollywood studios are in
Burbank are in and around the Los
Angeles area it's very close so because
this is not spoilery i just broke this
down top-5 style just hitting all the
major aspects of the film starting with
number five overwhelmingly all the
reviews praised it as a solid hit for DC
movies which i think is probably one of
the most important things if not the
most important thing will it be okay
will it be the beginning of or the end
of the Aquaman franchise there's so much
talk about the future of DC movies and
they're trying so many different types
of movies and characters that you just
don't know what's gonna stick so like
right now so many of those big actors
are on the fence like how many more
movies we're gonna get with Henry Cavill
or Ben Affleck who knows so it's good to
hear that most people are pretty
positive on the film but you can never
assume too much from these early reviews
because a really good recent comparison
is the venom movie a film that had a ton
of hype before all the test screenings
then after all the critics started to
see it the early reviews were decidedly
negative or mixed venom right now
currently has a rotten tomato score of
29% and has already made more than half
a billion dollars worldwide you may have
heard recently - it just premiered in
China and had the biggest superhero
movie opening box office of all time
there so regardless of what critics
think about it is a guaranteed sequel
it's a bit of a reverse situation for
the Aquaman movie heading into it
because the early buzz is about 5050
with people just being really wary about
the tonal shift of the character
and all the other things that are going
on in the related movies like all the
recent Batman Superman news there's just
a lot of uncertainty inside the DC
Universe so everyone's just not quite
sure what to make of the fast and
furious version of Aquaman but I think
that if you have a vested interest in
the fandom and seeing DC movies do well
then I don't think there's anything
really big to worry about for the
Aquaman movie just based on these early
reviews there's very few big movies like
this that people are unanimous about so
if venom can survive mixed reviews so
can Aquaman for next big thing reviews
are also 50/50 on the music score but
this being an earlier cut of the film
maybe you could chalk that up to being
not totally finished the person that's
doing the music for this is Rupert
gregson-williams he's the same person
that did the music for the Wonder Woman
movie so if you liked her soundtrack
have similar expectations for the
Aquaman soundtrack with a bend towards
swashbuckling adventures like a mixture
of the soundtracks from Pirates of the
Caribbean Indiana Jones in the other DC
movies there's a certain spread with
superhero soundtracks and theme songs
but I'm hoping that they can deliver an
Aquaman theme this is memorable is say
like the Wonder Woman theme which
actually you can thank Hans Zimmer for
in fun fact - side note Hans Zimmer
previously said he was kind of burnt out
on doing music for superhero movies
especially after all the DC movies that
he has done so far but he recently
agreed to come back and do the music for
Wonder Woman 1984 what you think is
great he's always a solid bet getting
into the special-effects action
categories 3 these early reviews say
pretty decent special effects at least
in the state that they were watching
them in I'm sure that there are probably
going to be changes to the edits as we
get closer to the film coming out the
main thing most people were worried
about initially when it came to special
effects before we started getting all
this footage and trailers was how they
were gonna handle all the underwater
stuff because most of the major moments
in this movie take place in aquatic
environments in water is historically
difficult to do from a special-effects
standpoint both water and fire so the
big problem during Justice League that
you may not have realized is is that
Arthur and Mira talked to each other but
there's only that one scene and she has
to create an air bubble so they can
communicate so when we got to Aquaman
most of that movie is gonna be
underwater with a lot of dialogue so
people were just like what are you gonna
do are you just gonna have air bubbles
through the entire movie how
gonna talk to each other this will be
crazy so the funny thing that James once
said is that early on because he'd been
working on the movie for a while
especially when we saw Justice League is
that the easy solution that he came up
with for that and it'll sound kind of
silly in how simple it is was to just
not worry about underwater stuff at all
he shot all the underwater scenes to
look mostly as if they were happening on
dry land with tweaks to the way light
bounces off of things and added some
obviously motion effects when they're
moving really fast underwater but aside
from some digital hair tuning when
they're walking around normally or being
still and just having a conversation
with each other you almost wouldn't be
able to tell that they're underwater
without a few visual cues to remind you
that is why it was so weird going from
Justice League footage to seeing that
very first Aquaman footage in the way
that they did that because it's so
different you took a hell of a head
you are not going to win this billions
will die unless you help us
most big Hollywood movies have done
underwater scenes the same way you saw
during Justice League the way people
look underwater the way they move
through water the way they communicate
while they're in water so this is just a
big seismic shift in the way it's done
the avatar sequels you may have heard
James Cameron talking about one of them
is gonna be underwater it'll be a really
fun to see the way he solves that
problem so it might be a little weird
for you for a second but if you've seen
a couple of the trailers it doesn't
sound like it caused any problems for
these early reviewers that were watching
the full cut of the film two really good
news there was high praise for the
overall storyline the action no real big
surprises there that are adapting
Justice League throne of Atlantis mixed
with Geoff Johns new 52 Aquaman run
unite the seven seas both solid stories
can't go wrong they're very epic and
James Wan has already shown that he
knows how to shoot a big action movie I
keep saying fast and furious that's one
of the aspects of the film that I've
never been particularly worried about
but number one probably the other most
important thing were the early reviews
of Aquaman and Mira's scenes together as
in their chemistry how do they feel
together do they play off of each other
because they're a pretty big couple in
the comics and it's implied if this
turns into a franchise then that would
be a much bigger thing in future movies
most of the trailer scenes we've seen
with them are out of context and don't
really give you a good sense for how
they played together when they're just
walking around as a potential couple so
early response on whatever the cut of
the film they were watching whereas they
were 50/50 they say hit or miss nothing
of course it's not working it's been
sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert you do your best
thinking when you're not thinking at all
right now hold still hey what are you
doing we need water you need a closest
source
[Music]
so because these are all test screenings
they're just trying to see how normal
audiences respond to this a lot of those
types of scenes can change in the Edit
because it's a lot easier to fix stuff
like that than it is like a really giant
special effects scene like a big battle
you see in the trailer here that takes
them six months to complete Jason Momoa
is outstanding when it comes to that
tough-guy sense of humor that you see
him in especially during Justice League
I felt like he fit into the group really
well because you have the flash
providing most of the comedy in the
comedy of Aquaman is mostly in the way
that he reacts to crazy stuff like that
just like a bad mera seems like she's
the one that's providing most of the
commentary when they're walking around
together and he's the one reacting up of
her unfortunately there wasn't anything
really specific about Black Manta ocean
master Ernie the other supporting cast
but hopefully we'll get more details
about them as we get a little bit closer
but from everything we've been hearing
from all these screenings it seems like
it'll be fine I would expect it to get a
sequel but how quickly they make an
Aquaman sequel just depends on the box
office Black Panther is a good example
one of the biggest superhero movie hits
of all time and Marvel is waiting three
years to release Black Panther 2 so
don't be surprised if Aquaman does
decently but they don't release Aquaman
2 until 2021
no worries regardless of what goes down
I will do videos for everything let me
know in the comments though what are you
most excited for for the Aquaman movie
it's a very different type of franchise
we just haven't spent a whole lot of
time underwater in the DC Universe so
there is a lot of fresh comic book
territory for them to mine and the DC
Universe there's some new Game of
Thrones and other videos that I'm
working on so I'll try to post those as
fast as possible but leave all your
requests in the comments below click
here for that brand new alternate ending
to infinity war and click here to
rewatch that extended Aquaman trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you